يَا أَغْنَامِي يا أغنامِي *** اِنْطَلِقِي بِالمَرْجِ النَّامِي
رَائِعَةٌ نَسَمَاتُ المَرْعَى *** مُمْتَدٌ بِالعُشْبِ أَمَامِي
طَرَأَتْ لِلرَاعِي أَفْكَارْ *** أَنْ يَمْرحَ ويُدَبِّرُ مَقْلَبْ
يَتَظَاهَرُ بِهُجُومِ الذِّئْبِ *** أَنْ يَلْهُو بِالكَذِبِ ويَلْعَبْ
النَّجْدَةْ هَاجَمَنَا الذِّئبْ  *** النَّجْدَةْ إِنِّي فِي وَرْطَةْ
يَا وَيْلِي يَأْكُلُ غَنَمَاتِي *** وعَلَيْهَا المُتَوَحِشُ نَطْ
هَرَعَ النَّاسُ إِلَيْهِ جَمِيعًا *** ولِنَجْدَتِهِ بأِقْصَى سُرْعَةْ
كَانَ المَرْعَى جِدًا هَادِيْء *** والنَّعْجَاتُ هُنَالِكَ تَرْعَى
أَنَا أَمْزَحُ مَعَكُمْ أَصْحَابِي *** حَتَّى أُرِيَكُمْ كَمْ أَنَا بَارِعْ
ولأَعْرِفَ مَنْ مِنْكُمْ يَأْتِي ***  فِي فَزَعٍ يَجْرِي ويُسَارِعْ
ارْتَفَعَتْ ضَحِكَاتُ الرَّاعِي ***  رَوَّعَهُمْ بِالكَذِبِ ويَسْخَرْ
غَضِبَ النَّاسُ وقَالُوا حَتْمًا *** يَوْمًا مَا بِالكَذِبِ سَيَخْسَرْ
يَنْجَحُ دَوْمًا هَذَا المَقْلَبْ *** والنَّاسُ تٌوَلْوِلُ وَتُهَرْوِلْ
لَكِنْ لاَ..مَا   هَذَا الصَّوْتْ؟ ***  ذِئْبٌ فِي قُرْبِي  يَتَجَوَّلْ
صَرَخَ الرَّاعِي صَرَخَ وصرخَ *** يَطْلُبُ يَهْتِفُ أَيْنَ المنجد
لَكِنْ لَمْ يَلْحَقْهُ النَّاس *** لِنَجْدَتِهِ لم يأتيه أَحَدَا
آَهٌ آَهٌ يَا أَغْنَامِي  *** هَذَا كَانَ نَتِيجَةَ كَذِبِي
قَدْ يَأْكُلَنِي الذِّئْبُ سَأَهْرُبْ *** فِي حُزْنٍ يَتَأَلَمُ قَلْبِي
قَالَ النَّاسُ لِذَاكَ الرَّاعِي  *** الكَاذِبُ لاَ يَجْنِي خَيْرَا
يَفْقِدُ ثِقَةَ الغَيْرِ وأَيْضًا *** يَتَنَدَّمُ يَبْكِي فِي حَسْرَة